from timcast.com European commission VP
says U.S will soon impose hate speech
laws and it seems like a simple
statement and it's easy to shrug off but
you know going to the bigger context in
the previous segment we're talking about
these evil people their their plans you
got Brian stelter sitting on stage with
these people and they say soon the U.S
will have you know will make hate speech
illegal to them hate speeches opinions
they disagree with hate speech is
disinformation and what's happening is
are these Davos Elite types are
infiltrating big Tech they're
infiltrating elements of the government
and they're imposing these insane rules
not through law
I don't necessarily know if anytime soon
they'll make it illegal they'll make it
impossible said a bad word as everybody
knows your car won't start you can't buy
your your credit card gets turned off
we've already seen it happen how many
people have been debanked bad opinions
no more no more bank for you that's
insane yeah so these these are the
people who are meeting and these big
event and these big meetings they're
bringing people like Brian stelter
they're bringing Democrat politicians to
sit down and say they want to control
what you see think and hear yeah Joe
manchin uh was at Davos making arguments
against the Open Press right like what's
wrong what's wrong with the freaking
Open Press Tony Blair was openly talking
about we need a a international vaccine
passport system where we track people's
medical records and allow them to go
places and not places there's another
heart attacks exactly yes uh yeah I
could say a lot more uh how about that
particularly there was also another
member of a big tech company talking
about how he welcomes the FBI
involvement with uh specifically
cloudflare the CEO of cloudflare came
out and says that he welcomes guidance
from the FBI so so so there's a reason
why the FBI Direct also attends Davos as
well there's there's a reason why they
have a lot of public meetings but they
also have a lot of secret meetings as
well and obviously one hand uh what's
the saying here one hand of washes
washes the other hand here and and
there's a collective interest here of a
lot of these powerful power Brokers
essentially just saying you know you
help me I help you but we're going to
make sure that we come out on top when
we get to essentially take all of
people's Liberties and financial
freedoms away from them
and then that's the game here that's
that's the con here it's it's clear as
day and and they're using these kind of
bland generalized language to to to get
away with it well the reason they get
away with it more importantly though and
this is why the most important
conversation when people say what do we
do to correct it it's the education
battle because the reason is because
there are two we're producing too many
stupid people right who cannot think
through these policies and this is when
you go what is happening on college
campuses why are we having debates about
why are there gender studies Majors this
is a true fact we've never we've never
given out more degrees in America ever
and yet we've never produce Dumber kids
I mean literally Dumber kids I'm talking
about if you sat them down with an IQ
test these kids are actually dumb so how
is that possible that should run in
conflict with one another how are we
giving the most degrees you're producing
the dumbest kids because it's a concert
effort by the government because they
understand you want to talk about real
slavery slaves I wrote this in my book
oh another free pitch for myself
Blackout
um I wrote this in my book but my thesis
is that what they're basically doing is
modernizing the slave plantation right
you can't now take people into chains
but what was one element of a slave
plantation station well it was that
slaves weren't allowed to learn how to
read these were called slave quotes So
what better way than to make people
think that they're learning how to read
but they're learning nothing they're
learning be scared the plan is going to
be dead in 10 years men can be women
women can be men I have a degree I'm so
smart should they come out super
arrogant convinced that they know
everything and they quite literally if
you drop them off in a forest they'd all
be dead in a week right they literally
know nothing this is all a part of the
big plan right the idea is to produce
dumb people intentionally and think
about this we hear from people like Bill
Gates and a lot of these Davos types
where it's you know we got to reduce
population growth we see a lot of
actions taken that not only reduce
population but also stagnate the economy
think about what happens if you've got
someone who works on a Foundry you know
they're like you know they're making
let's just say let's just say widgets
they're they're smelting metal and doing
all stuff and then Along Comes a college
grad with a degree in gender studies
adding a Dei specialist to The Foundry
serves only one purpose it slows the
economic activity it causes internal
conflict which damages their ability to
produce either the United States is
being destroyed for this reason or or
with this tactic or it is inadvertently
being destroyed by this question this is
what gender this is where gender studies
and black lives matter and the racial
initiatives lock arms right oh now you
should hire Talent based on the color of
their skin where's your diversity and
inclusion Department what is that doing
right it's counterintuitive to the free
market it's counterintuitive to
businesses that are growing and becoming
productive as a higher people that know
absolutely nothing but I got to have
this whole department with 10 people
that are hired because one's black one's
gay and that means that I'm a good
business and people are losing money
because this is this obviously this is
not a sound economic model and so there
this is much more Machiavellian people
say that the left is stupid oh they
think yeah the people that listen to the
left you maybe you can maybe challenge
it they're actually not even stupid
they're brainwashed it's not really
their fault like brainwash is real
propaganda is real it has real effects
especially when it's taking place in the
classroom where they're spending six
hours a day they're not even stupid
they're brainwashed you should you
should sympathize rather than call them
stupid but the people at the top that
are that are producing this that are
that want this to happen this is
Machiavellian these people are are
insane they're Psychopaths and they know
exactly what they're doing that's what's
something I thought while you were
saying explaining earlier is that what's
more dangerous than having a group of
uneducated people is having a group of
miseducated people that have been
educated for nefarious purposes because
it's harder to untrain the brain than it
is to give it something new especially
when you give it a degree because when
you give it a degree what you're giving
them is they they think they're smart oh
my gosh the number one thing that the
left says to me is well you didn't even
graduate college like the that's that's
there okay so let me get this straight
I'm I'm doing better than you I have a
larger audience you but you have a
little paper degree so they go out and
those people then get really angry
because they try that degree in a free
market Society they have no success and
they become bitter angry resentful
perfect little leftists that will March
in the street talking about how this
entire system needs to be burned to the
ground because how do they not become
successful when they have a degree you
know you know I like to say when because
because they used to be all the time
they'll tweet like yeah see this proves
Tim's a high school dropout or don't
listen to his high school dropout did
you drop out of high school yeah oh wow
and my response is your high school
diploma in five and five bucks will get
you a cup of coffee it should be three
dollars but thanks to the way you voted
it's now five dollars
but it's the number one thing it gives
them this inflated ego like they
actually think even though their entire
life tells them their remarkable failure
but I have a degree it's like my guy oh
okay they're yeah be humble you know
what I mean like look I don't expect
everybody in the world to be a
millionaire I don't expect everybody to
have a six figure salary if you're
somebody who works an honest job and
says you know look I did everything told
me to do if someone came to me and said
look man I went to college I got my
degree I worked really hard and I make
thirty five thousand thousand years an
administrative assistant I'd be like you
know look man we'll I'll try and give
you some advice and help you out you
know just be humble like you know we're
trying we're trying to help you out it's
not it's it's I don't think it's
society's fault I'm sorry I don't think
it's the individual's fault that they
were lied to by the machine and tricking
them into getting a student loan debts
and all this stuff but if you come out
and you're like I'm so much smarter than
you because I finished high school I
make thirty thousand dollars a year I'll
be like my guy please you just say yes
you are that's right yes you are almost
hey what the Rockefeller family did when
it came to shaping modern education was
was pretty smart was pretty billion they
made a lot of good Factory workers that
regurgitate and repeat everything
they're told to repeat they follow all
their orders they make sure that they
get the job done for the boss and what
what else did you think brings us to Big
farmer if you're going to talk about
Rockefeller you can you can you have to
mention big Pharma right you literally
have doctors that are graduating Harvard
right now I cover this on my podcast
this week they are graduating Harvard
and they believe that children are born
with the ability to pick their gender I
mean like like they're talking about
infants right now I color this on my
show infants they believe have within
them possessed within them the knowledge
to know that they're in the wrong body
right I have an infant
an infant knows absolutely nothing we
know but this is these people now are
convinced that they're brighter than you
because they're a doctor and they became
a doctor because they graduated from
Harvard you I'm like you I know you went
to University you have to go to
university to be that dumb nowadays it's
you have to spend four years in school
to be this stupid I can't I can't
remember this but my mom tells people
that when I was little when asked what I
wanted to be when I grew up I would say
a pumpkin
because like being a little kid who
doesn't understand concepts of like
reality jobs or otherwise I I was like I
don't remember saying that but I mean it
sounds like something a three-year-old
would say is that why you started this
company I wanted to be a pumpkin it's
research and development well we'll get
there in the in the basement
identify as a pumpkin
oh you're right we get tattoos you were
so smart you were so smart you were so
ahead of your time we've got a genetics
lab in the basement and all of the all
of your all of your super chats all of
your Tim cast membership go into DNA
manipulation to convert human cells into
pumpkins human chimeras the noise keeps
me up at night I just tell myself
they're chicken no but like a little kid
doesn't know anything I'm joking by the
way they believe in infant no I mean
it's it's crazy it is crazy what's
happening are they being told that at
Harvard while they're learning it in a
book that's a problem if you want to
trick a person like that is a student
just put an academic put it in a book
literally it's incredible to me this
goes to the Sam Harris thing I don't
know if you guys are friends with him
please go back and find Sam Harris in
our com on our little debate on Twitter
the things that he called me because you
know why because Sam Harris has a degree
and then it was literally the funniest
competition ever Dave Rubin tried to
like be like oh two people that I'm
friends with like I don't want them
fighting you guys should get on the
phone like this is Dave Reuben's credit
by the way and he gives Sam Harris my
number he calls him this is the day that
they announced that like Cove it's
happening and things are going to shut
down I'm in Texas I'm about to go to an
event and he sounds like he's in a
effing bunker like he sounded like a
cute crazy person he's like you don't
understand this thing's gonna get really
bad and like I spoke to my doctors and
you don't I know people I know doctors
that are in Italy in you know in in two
weeks there's going to be gurneys in the
streets nobody's gonna be able to go
anywhere Candace please you have to be
responsible with your platform you need
to encourage people to get inside where
I mean he literally talk about a
conversation I should have recorded
right because this is like it was
stunning he went crazy and then and then
he went on other podcasts and he called
me I mean a categorical imbecile all
these things you know why because he
went and he got a degree and he called
his doctor friends and his doctor
friends all said they understood this
thing because they were reading what was
in a book and now they were reading
studies it's like all you have to do to
trick an academic is to put it in a book
and it becomes magically real and they
suspend their ability to think quickly
because that's what too much schooling
does it's suspends your ability to think
critically because your job in these at
these University campuses is to remember
information to regurgitate information
it's not to think quickly and go wait a
second let's just defies common sense
right you know they just go oh but it's
right here it's right here it's passage
but but more importantly it's also to
follow the hierarchy so if there's a
boss if there's someone paying you if
there's like a Bill Gates creating
something like the bill chill in the
scientific Community you cannot
criticize that because if you do you're
going to get your funding cut from you
and people don't understand especially
when it comes to American history there
have been so many Horrors in American
history that I have been done through
doctors whether it was the Tuskegee
experiments the MK Ultra experiments
Operation Sea spray that's another one
which became the MMR vaccine the secret
government
poisoning of of San Francisco residents
with a plutonium oh yeah there's there's
also the forced sterilization that has
happened all throughout this country uh
since the 1900s all the way up to 2010
the Florida California right now that
makes no effing sense scientifically the
worst Horrors that Humanity faced were
rubber stamped by doctors that were
following orders and just doing what
they were told hey tell me real quick
what's the operation sea spray Operation
Sea spray is when the US government was
was doing a bioweapons experiment on San
Francisco in the 1950s
was that when they were they were
spraying or something on people Secret
in which ceratia
Mark ascends and basilius
globigi bacteria were sprayed over San
Francisco Bay area in California to
determine how vulnerable a city like San
Francisco may be to buy a weapon exactly
1950 1950 that's like right out of that
military industrial complex this is all
the stuff that we know about so this is
what the what the secret agencies with
the federal government was doing decades
and decades ago there's probably still a
bunch of stuff that we don't know about
today but the sterilization aspect is
one of the biggest because it continued
all the way up to up to 2010 when
Californian women prisoners without
their uh knowledge were being sterilized
by the government so this has been
happening for a very long time there's a
lot of eugenicists out there there's a
lot of people that believe that there's
too many people in this world and they
have created so many Horrors that need
to be addressed and rectified and this
is public knowledge imagine what's
secret do you guys know about the human
Z no the Chip sounds like a human
chimpanzee that's right and so it's you
know if you read about it they'll tell
you it's it's hypothesized there's urban
legends about it
but I'm sorry man if you think that the
various governments of the world did not
try to create chimeric human hybrids and
other weird nonsense then you're naive
yeah now Alex Jones coming out and
saying they're making cow people and
stuff maybe a stretch too far but
there's there's an old story about
apparently apparently the urban legend
is that and maybe it's history in the
Soviet Union
they were uh taking human women and
inseminating them with chimp semen yes
because you can't do it the other way
around because chimps are too small a
female chimp can't carry a human baby
it's too big but a human female can
carry a human Z because it's smaller and
so they were like offering women money
or just forcefully doing this you think
the United States isn't doing anything
like that they're definitely doing this
is like funding it and then having it
done in China what do you think I mean
the covet vaccine like no I guess we'll
wait till we're behind us
total VidCon move but like a lot I want
to say about the vaccine and by the way
I said a lot of stuff at the best seen
publicly on my show I mean I you guys
know I do not back to my children yeah I
am like I think maybe the only vocally
person that says proudly that I am
anti-vaxxas that little like smear of
Cam oh you anti-backs I'm like yes put
it on my check I get in a badge form
like thank you I had to help these
children in the entire world I was
injured by a vaccine you're not going to
Gaslight me against an injury and I
suffered everything you just said ditto
oh well we actually we actually do have
a story we can talk about the members
only show that Luke was bringing up
which will be really interesting and
there's a lot more we can add yeah about
you know uh bump stock Donnie there but
that's a separate that's a separate
subject there but but
um again human experimentation has been
done by so many high-level government
officials and what they're doing right
now I can't we can't even imagine and
it's not just being done in Ukraine with
uh the specific gain of function
research they're doing there it's not
just being done in China it's being done
domestically there's a lot of things
that again we could get into the weeds
we could go down the rabbit hole
especially when it comes to Lyme disease
agent orange gay bombs exactly
you mentioned it was led to the MMOs
yeah I mean the DDT scan people if you
want to really start learning about
vaccines it all begins people believing
that polio was eradicated and LOL if
your starting level is you think that
polio was eradicated there's so much
that people have to understand about
vaccines I am now of a very formed
opinion that I believe that there is a
true government war on fertility they
want to own the means of fertility and
this is big this is happening in the
classroom with convincing women when
we're 13 to get on birth control pills
and telling you there's no effect
there's no effect in me taking hormones
every single day that's crazy really
there's going to be no effect to me
taking hormone pills every how stupid I
mean again common sense but I read it I
read it a book
there's a sterilization program being
run right now against the people of this
world and many people don't even realize
it and I just want to add to just just
to stop and think about how crazy it is
that we Mass hormonally medicate females
in this country and mass and there there
are people I know that that uh women who
are said never touched I had a bad
feeling about it in my gut when I was 13
and every time I went to the doctor like
if I was like oh my head hurts to be
like birth control I was like oh like my
belly hurts like birth control I'm like
oh I have a cramp they're like birth
control I'm like okay well this can't be
like an all-catch pill why are you
trying to try to get me on birth control
pill and I just thank God I had that
spiritual Assurance I was like this is
weird this is weird it is weird it
destroys women for the rest of their
life I really do I thought this is
horrible thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time